rebound Tony Bradley put it all right
here great timing Georges Niang nice
nice dunk one da putting it away great
timing great lift well here he is
jumping to the rim on a beautiful move
by the third-year Pro out of Louisville
Utah v Rick James in transition look at
Mitchell on the intended projection
calmly got fouled by Bradley no call and
Wow
it's a hot potater and nobody wants it
but Mitchell says fine I'll finish it it
back into the picture this is the easy
deuce for LeBron but doesn't quit on
having head up high as you strike going
on
pick it out Joe his boys on a drive
needs it inside
but this play is a beauty Royce sky-high
he takes it over Yanis voice O'Neal
let's see who they're gonna try to break
free it's brought down a [ __ ]
barbar beautiful and bad bye Joe
easily down with two tents on the clock
as the horn sounds the jazz with it
all the celebration yeah happiness it
tear yeah dear happiness brought him to
tears
oh my accounts that is a 3-ball down is
one more time he had to rush it and he
runs it home and by the way players do
practice he shots a Monday saying that's
any easier but a practice he's before
they've beefed courts and Conley got one
you see he had a shoot at the shot clock
going down nothing but bottom of the net
come on Mike smile Jill ran by him on a
twenty point half and really came up to
you people maybe got kneed in the cab
he's grabbing that that left calf trying
to walk it off with 24 on the jump shot
charlie all baby beautiful he went up
high the paint clear he took advantage
Matt eight for eight 18 points nine
rebounds
Conley's dished out four assists and the
Jazz are ruling and how about that hot
flying down of a Mitchell I love it
doubt of it 78 61 Utah towns against go
bear put the shoulder down rolls inside
try to Santa home and really said
Peggy free right here
attempt denied
nice rejection
because the works and handles gee he
went right left
Budhia stayed with him nice lob Joe
Moody
this booty a bucket look like he was
going be hot in the back right here kept
it and whoopsie
Korver goes where'd you go I'm right
here pal yeah he pulled us all on that
one but what a beautiful shot right here
by Modi a jazz by to Minnesota still
just three of their last 11 from the
floor down to the rainbows up a shot
[Applause]
[Music]
Court saying is that good enough
I'm gonna quick 26 Donovan just rolling
with 206 on the floor 500 you bogey here
kind of a hook pass the ball is in the
air and Gobert is just waiting on it
great hands by Gobert he goes up and
gets it and hammers at home and Matt you
see we're eight execution each one put
down that
[Applause]
floated home did he do it
type moment Wow he gets up and puts it
right on the face of Mele posterized
stare down
oh my welcome to ESPN top ten have them
step up and be that vocal leader is huge
we rely on his presence in particular
when he has nights like he had in
Memphis we feed off that KK you saw it
beautiful Dunkerley without hair styling
I've been coming off whoa that's an
angry duck a little bit see the cross
behind the back and then go up angry
dunk it
[Applause]
well the blender was going boys takes a
shot without a Mitchell man he just
takes off timing this just perfect with
the left-handed slam forces 14-point
make that 12 on the night the outside is
not working let's see what happens
inside the house
gamba Mitchell going to the roof right
here des needed that one well that's
just a beautiful theater signal
basically picks the pocket a young final
hide La Paz Oh Donovan behind it back to
go bear beautiful what a little
beautiful flood since a 2322 score late
in the first quarter a thing of beauty
and a jazz lead by 1/8 shots taken
tonight by Ingles for his 19 points he
looks inside Rudy what I ever my the
high-flying go bear this is gonna be
highlight reel time watch go bear go up
and over he's a foot over Leonard and
just dunks it right on top of his head
nice work go there
[Applause]
two-time Defensive Player of the Year
thumbs up with the biggest block of the
game here yep
I will send Bogdanovich to the
free-throw line and Rudy Gobert who is
Mike Mitchell so gifted offensively the
pump fake happens and then he goes to
the rim and when he is in flight watch
out there get out of the way cuz he's
gonna try to dunk it on you check out
the bench pausing the defense not to
have as much energy on that end
just a 35-point half
[Applause]
and puffs home too first of all no one's
gonna try to challenge look at Drummond
he's thinking about he says once Dominic
gets in the air no way but you loved the
foot action at Donovan when he gets in
the air he's so high although that he's
able to kick his legs out it's almost
like what Jordan used to do and he
brought that to the NBA good time for
halftime for the jazz angles gives it up
Donovan oh thanks at home that's gonna
count at the end the first half we see
the quick replay yeah it definitely
gonna count
what awareness by Donovan 17 and the
terrific young player was speed then it
feels like another Road game but not for
Utah thus far in the first quarter but
here's that beautiful lob and over the
shoulders over the head for two yeah not
for those two I mean they're so familiar
with the job what his job is to bring
some excitement off that bench the
defensive minded but do it to do that
school
[Applause]
there's a nice connection right here
Mike Conley the roofers we're up there
the stretch out dunk there's a
pick-and-roll for some chunks and his
see here's this dog as Georgina delivers
a ball perfectly and a two-hand slam at
this let's pinch both is awesome just
explode suitable treyton buckets right
in the left long 3 pumped up by Turner
and the Jazz come out with it torso
kneel maybe bang Denis inside Oh
as a governor goes to work out of the
perimeter moody gets turned around
like where'd he come from
attic play by Colbert
oh that's a great flock
our chinchilla miss on Allah
lots of done Mitchell thing of beauty
Donovan Mitchell gets up higher than the
rest looking and kick his legs out
incredible athletic ability catches it
finishes at the rim that'll be on the
highlight reel
there we go who's gonna take this shot
to try to tire went outside the bogie
he's crowded
[Applause]
the Lord
winds in Houston
Figg
even nearly ripped that Jersey run haha
can't blame her and the Jazz now I've
won two in a row this one in really
dynamic fashion watch buggy half to the
shop this is what I love
oh my goodness
team's loving it
yes the crowd is alive at American
Airlines Center Donovan Mitchell on a
stop-and-go Drive spins inside inside to
Gobert he'll spin past porzingis it puts
it home with two hands it's a couple of
window opportunities but they got this
one right
I thought you even got fouled on it but
really go bears saying listen you're
coming in to me I'm gonna make this one
count
stay on his feet still bought that shot
kick it out to Joe
check out Rudy seals none underneath the
basket Eagles throws it high where only
he can get it and finished the reverse
dunk that's that's good stuff
great very quiet hardened takes on
Mitchell turns them around window and it
will be
Tucker falls and falls down this is an
amazing play little crossover double
cross one hand gets fouled by Tucker
gets up like he's a man on a mission
ouch like what he said that he needed to
do it shoot around this morning to get
going rather than try to go for a far
deep three just get an easy bucket loses
and I'm playing bad then it's on me
here's Donovan on the dunk
he's got spring in his legs me gets
those two legs together he's more of a
two-footed jumper than one got Springs
in those legs man hmm
but taking ownership of when you're
playing bad